france24 pudo dialogar con mario picazo
el meteorólogo en the weather network y
el tiempo de españa' acerca del avance
de estos incendios y también sobre cómo
combatirlos en este contexto tan
particular de pandemia y esto nos decía
y aquí lo que tenemos que preocuparnos
ahora mismo es sobretodo de las labores
de extinción cómo podemos hacer para que
estos incendios no se propaguen sean
sean cuales sean las condiciones
atmosféricas de hace más viento hay una
ola de calor o lo que sea lógicamente lo
que se trata de la gestión del monte ya
pasó se tenía que haber hecho mejor
durante la primavera y el invierno pero
este año ha sido especial sobre todo por
la situación del cob y no ha habido
tantos medios para cuidar el monte para
protegernos de los incendios y por lo
tanto ahora se trata sobre todo de tener
recursos humanos para luchar contra
estos incendios cosa que también es
complicada por la situación del cob y
porque este año no se puede contar con
tanta gente con otros años y por lo
tanto los recursos humanos no son los
suficientes en cuanto al futuro de todos
estos incendios nos va a tener un
impacto tremendo directamente pues por
supuesto porque estos intereses están
generando mucho humo esas nubes de humo
lo que hacen es de alguna forma bloquear
la radiación solar pues aquí ya
anticipamos que este sería como una gran
erupción volcánica podría haber un
enfriamiento durante los próximos meses
pero a la vez también sabemos que
algunas de las partículas que generan
estos incendios pueden provocar
calentamiento ahí todavía estamos
investigando
cuál de los dos pesa más por otra parte
habrá un impacto tremendo en la
superficie